back in first of all congratulations an
important Victory against a tough
opponent you won the first game with the
white pieces and you had to defend a
very difficult game with the black
pieces how did you prepare for this one
and take us through the game
sure like I forgot to check night and
night pt7 for some reason so I tried to
play a logical chess but unfortunately
after Queen E3 it's not that great
already I was going to play Queen C6 but
I was like let's be more solid my coach
told me hi there King and then you know
that was my main advice you just try to
keep the king safe yeah that was the
thing but
I mean I try not to blunder the
unfortunately I was going I had to
develop my my Rook on H1 so I decided
that this position is not that bad you
still had some compensation yeah I have
a feeling
I thought Bishop on H4 is kind of strong
because Rook d8 she cannot play which is
a very important square and I'm
controlling and she cannot play G5 she
doesn't really have time for F6 too so I
was like okay as long as I can put King
H2 I'm not losing so I was confident
about the position and then I think
whatever she did is not the like the
best now she cannot take only four
because of Knight 27 check ideas so you
got your Pawn back you outplayed her in
this game and then once again let's get
to the final game that you played the
Petrov defense did you expect this from
your opponent absolutely if we played
actually uh like recently in the summer
Warden Blitz and then I played the Blitz
game with her I played Petrov and I got
a good position but I managed to lose it
like I messed it up totally so I did
expect it and I do believe she did
expected it and she repeated her line
with Bishop F4
and last time I played Knight F6 after
Bishop before line but this time I
decided to try Knight C5 I didn't know
much I didn't have like a lot of time to
prepare I had to check other lines too
so I was like
okay I'm gonna just you know this is the
first time
you knew the plans you knew that she's
trying to attack him on this side and
you try to do something on the other
side I just remember when I just started
to play picture of my teammate told me
the most important thing you should do
is to play rookie eight Bishop f8 so I
just did it yes yes that makes a lot of
sense Rook takes C4 Rook to E8 and at
this point you found this nice little
tactic with Queen to E7 pick up the pawn
it's it's not easy to say is see it I
think she said okay B5 fishy
automatically plays C5 but like
unfortunately she's behind yes
that's why and I think we saw the game
after this move C3 we concluded that
your attack is probably going to be
successful which it was Becky
congratulations a big victory for you
tomorrow you will be facing Nazi paikiza
who won her match against tardev what is
your experience with her what do you
anticipate for that match actually we
didn't play many games maybe couple of
offs guys any questions our
congratulations bacon good luck in your
next match
nice and uh